welcome to CBS this morning Washington
is pushing to speed up hurricane relief
for desperate people in Puerto Rico
President Trump praised first responders
last night saying they are doing a great
job others say the government has moved
too slowly one Democratic senator asked
where's the Calvary the Pentagon is
sending three-star general Jeff Buchanan
to oversee some 10,000 federal forces
involved in relief efforts acting
Homeland Security Secretary Elaine Duke
goes to Puerto Rico today with other
senior administration officials to see
the devastation firsthand
well FEMA says it has delivered 2
million litres of drinking water and 1
million meals the focus now is on
delivering supplies to local
distribution sites David Beck knows in
Aguadilla that's on the west coast of
Puerto Rico where people there still
need a whole lot of help David good
morning good morning we're on the
western tip of the island this is where
Ayodhya is the first person we saw when
we got here was the mayor and he said go
anywhere and you will find destruction
this is a hotel right along the water
where they would have wedding parties
the entire front end has been blown out
looking at the water
there's devastation everywhere along the
shore people are running low on food
they've run out of water and lines to
get gas stretched for more than three
miles desperate yet incredibly patient
Puerto Ricans stood in line in the
pouring rain waiting to fuel their cars
and gas cans after what they've been
through the passing shower barely made
them flinch
lines for basic resources are a fact of
life here this grocery store has about
two weeks worth of food and they're
running low on water
nine days after Maria made landfall
Fabiola Perez stood in line for water
for the third day in a row
to stay home
the hurricane ripped off the roofs of
more than 1500 homes according to the
mayor Carlos Mendez who says his city
has been devastated entire towns are
isolated by fallen trees and roads that
are impassable in San Lorenzo the main
bridge has been washed out forcing
families to wade through the river with
garbage bags of supplies swung over
their shoulders
John Raven is a Regional Administrator
for FEMA who says damage is slowing
relief efforts a response to an incident
like this is complex it's difficult and
it is not nearly as fast as any of us
what people are suffering people are
trying motivate children's are trying
but the main things that we have to work
together we have to keep hope alive
we said mistake no to the road again
when you go down you have to get
what we're doing back here in Aguadilla
they stopped serving water yesterday at
4:30 because of the curfew nobody could
be out on the street
water will again be served today
starting at 8 a.m. for 60,000 people
they only have 4 water trucks and this
morning
they're only going to have 2,000 meals
to serve David Beck no in Puerto Rico
thanks David